Je devais parler de mon nouveau livre,
intitulé "Blink", c'est sur les jugements et les premières impressions.
Il va paraître en janvier et j'espère que vous en achèterez tous trois exemplaires.
Mais en y réfléchissant, je me suis rendu
compte que même si mon nouveau livre me rendait heureux,
je pense qu'il rendrait ma mère heureuse,
ce n'est pas vraiment un livre sur le bonheur.
Alors j'ai décidé à la place de parler de quelqu'un qui,
je pense, a fait autant pour rendre les Américains heureux
que toute autre personne sur les 20 dernières années.
Un homme qui est un grand héros pour moi.
Une personne nommée Howard Moskowitz,
qui est très connu pour avoir réinventé la sauce spaghetti.
Howard est à peu près grand comme ça et il est rond,
il a la soixantaine, d'énormes lunettes,
des cheveux gris, une espèce d'exubérance et de vitalité magnifiques,
un perroquet et il adore l'opéra,
enfin, c'est un grand amateur d'histoire médiévale.
Il est psychophysicien de métier.
Certes, je dois vous dire que je n'ai aucune idée de ce qu'est la psychophysique,
même si, à un moment de ma vie, je suis sorti pendant deux ans avec une fille qui préparait
son doctorat en psychophysique.
Cela vous laisse imaginer ce qu'était cette relation. (Rires)
A ma connaissance, la psychophysique concerne la mesure des choses.
Howard est très intéressé par la mesure des choses.
Il a obtenu son doctorat à Harvard,
et monté une petite agence de conseil à White Plains dans l'état de New York.
Un de ses premiers clients--ceci remonte à plusieurs années, au début des années 70--
un de ses premiers clients a été Pepsi.
Les gens Pepsi sont venus voir Howard et lui ont dit:
"Vous savez, il y a cette nouveauté appelée aspartame,
et nous voudrions faire du Pepsi Light.
Nous aimerions que vous trouviez quelle quantité mettre
dans chaque canette de Pepsi Light, afin d'avoir la boisson parfaite".
Il semble à tous qu'il existe une réponse incroyablement simple à cette question,
et c'est ce que pensait Howard. Parce que Pepsi lui a dit :
"Nous sommes sur un intervalle de 8 à 12%.
En dessous de huit, ce n'est pas assez sucré,
au dessus de 12, c'est trop sucré.
Nous voulons savoir quel est l'idéal entre 8 et 12?"
Si je vous donnais ce problème à résoudre, vous diriez tous, c'est très simple.
Ce qu'il faut faire, c'est réaliser des mélanges expérimentaux,
à chaque degré de douceur : 8%, 8,1, 8,2, 8,3,
jusqu'à 12 -- les essayer avec des milliers de personnes,
et tracer les résultats sur une courbe,
puis retenir la concentration la plus populaire. Très simple.
Howard fait l'expérience, obtient les données, les utilise pour tracer une courbe,
et soudain réalise que ce n'est pas une jolie courbe en cloche.
En fait, les données n'ont aucun sens.
C'est un désordre total. Il y en a partout.
La plupart des gens de ce secteur des essais sur les aliments
n'est pas consternée lorsque les données n'ont pas de sens.
Ils se disent : "Deviner ce que les gens pensent des boissons gazeuses n'est pas facile.
Nous avons peut-être fait une erreur quelque part.
Faisons juste une estimation intelligente."
Et ils choisissent 10 pour cent, juste au milieu.
Howard n'est pas apaisé aussi facilement.
Howard est un homme avec un certain niveau intellectuel.
Tout ceci n'était pas assez bien pour lui,
et cette question l'a hanté pendant des années.
Il y repensait : "Qu'est-ce qui n'a pas marché?"
Pourquoi ne pouvait-on pas donner un sens à cette expérience avec Pepsi Light?
Un jour, alors qu'il était dans une cafétéria à White Plains,
sur le point d'inventer quelque chose pour Nescafé,
soudain, comme un éclair, la réponse lui est tombée dessus.
C'est que, quand ils ont analysé les données sur le Pepsi Light,
ils posaient la mauvaise question.
Ils cherchaient le Pepsi parfait,
alors qu'ils auraient dû chercher les Pepsis parfaits. Croyez-moi.
Cela a été une énorme révélation.
C'était une des plus brillantes découvertes dans toute la science des aliments.
Howard est immédiatement parti en croisade,
il allait à des conférences dans tout le pays,
se levait et disait,
"Vous cherchiez le Pepsi parfait. Vous avez tort.
Vous devriez chercher les Pepsis parfaits."
Et les gens le regardaient d'un air étonné et disaient,
"De quoi parlez-vous? Vous êtes fou."
Puis ils disaient, "Partez d'ici! Suivant!"
Il essayait de travailler, personne ne voulait l'engager -- il était obsédé, cependant,
il en parlait encore et encore.
Howard adore l'expression Yiddish
"Pour un ver dans du raifort, le monde est du raifort."
Ceci était son raifort. (Rires) Il en était obsédé!
Finalement, il a pu percer. Les gens de Vlasic Pickles sont venus le voir,
et lui ont dit: "M. Moskowitz -- Docteur Moskowitz --
nous voulons faire la sauce pickle parfaite." Il a répondu :
"La sauce parfaite n'existe pas, il y a seulement des sauces parfaites."
Il est revenu vers eux et leur a dit : "Non seulement vous devez améliorer votre sauce ordinaire,
mais vous devez aussi créer "zesty"."
C'est de là que viennent les pickles au zeste.
La personne suivante à venir le voir était Campbell's Soup.
C'était encore plus important. En fait,
Howard a fait sa réputation avec Campbell's Soup.
Campbell's a créé Prego, et au début des années 80, Prego avait du mal face à Ragu,
qui était la sauce spaghetti dominante des années 70 et 80.
Dans l'industrie--je ne sais pas si cela vous intéresse,
ou combien de temps je vais en parler.
C'était, techniquement parlant--c'est un aparté--
Prego est une sauce tomate bien meilleure que Ragu.
La qualité du concentré de tomate est meilleure, le mélange des épices est nettement supérieur,
elle colle aux pâtes d'une manière plus plaisante. En fait,
on a fait ce fameux test avec le bol dans les années 70 avec Ragu et Prego.
Vous avez un plat de spaghetti, et vous la versez dessus, d'accord?
Ragu se met tout au fond, Prego reste à la surface.
C'est ce qu'on appelle l'"adhérence".
De toute façon, même si elle était bien meilleure en termes d'adhérence,
et de qualité du concentré de tomate, Prego avait beaucoup de mal.
Alors ils se sont tournés vers Howard, et lui ont dit: "Trouvez-nous une solution."
Howard a examiné leur ligne de produits, et a dit:
"Vous avez est une société de tomates morte!"
Puis: "Voici ce que je veux faire."
Il a commencé à travailler avec la cuisine de Campbell's,
et a créé 45 variétés de sauce spaghetti. Il les a fait varier
pour obtenir autant de sauces tomate différentes possibles.
Selon la douceur, la quantité d'ail, l'acidité, la "tomatitude",
les morceaux -- mon terme favori dans le business de la sauce spaghetti. (Rires)
Il a décliné la sauce spaghetti de toutes les manières possibles.
Puis il a pris tout son lot de 45 sortes de sauces spaghetti et il est parti sur le terrain.
Il est parti à New York, Chicago, Jacksonville,
Los Angeles. Il rassemblait une foule de gens. Dans de grandes salles.
Il les invitait à s'asseoir pendant deux heures et leur donnait,
tout au long de ces deux heures, 10 bols.
Dix petits bols de pâtes, avec une sauce spaghetti différente dans chaque bol.
Après qu'ils avaient mangé chaque bol, ils devaient noter, de 0 à 100,
comment ils avaient trouvé la sauce spaghetti.
A la fin de ce processus, après l'avoir fait pendant des mois et des mois,
il avait une montagne de données
sur l'avis des Américains sur la sauce spaghetti.
Il a ensuite analysé les données.
A-t-il cherché la variété la mieux classée de toutes les variétés de sauce spaghetti? Non!
Howard ne croit pas qu'il en existe une.
A la place, il a examiné les données, et a dit:
"Voyons si nous pouvons diviser ces différentes données en groupes.
Voyons si ces groupes peuvent se réunir autour de certaines idées."
Inévitablement, si vous analysez toutes ces données sur la sauce spaghetti,
vous vous rendez compte qu'il existe trois groupes d'Américains.
Il y a ceux qui aiment leur sauce spaghetti nature,
ceux qui aiment leur sauce spaghetti épicée,
et ceux qui l'aiment avec plein de morceaux.
Parmi ces trois groupes, le troisième était le plus nombreux.
Car à cette époque, au début des années 1980,
si vous alliez dans un supermarché,
vous ne trouviez pas de sauce spaghetti avec plein de morceaux.
Les gens de Prego se sont tournés vers Howard et lui ont dit:
"Vous me dites qu'un tiers des Américains raffole de cette sauce
et que personne n'a encore répondu à leurs attentes?" Et il répondu: "Oui!"
(Rires) Prego est reparti,
a complètement reformulé ses sauces spaghetti,
et a commercialisé une nouvelle gamme qui a immédiatement et complètement
dominé le secteur des sauces spaghetti dans ce pays.
Pendant les 10 années suivantes, ils ont réalisé 600 millions de dollars
sur leur ligne de sauces avec des morceaux.
Tous ceux qui étaient dans l'industrie ont vu ce que Howard a fait et ont dit,
"Oh mon Dieu! Nous avions tout faux!"
C'est là qu'on a commencé à avoir sept sortes de vinaigre,
14 sortes de moutardes, et 71 variétés d'huile d'olive--
finalement même Ragu a fait travailler Howard,
et Howard a fait la même chose pour Ragu que pour Prego.
Aujourd'hui, si vous allez dans un très bon supermarché,
et que vous regardez combien il y a de sauces Ragu--
Savez-vous combien il y en a? 36!
Six variétés: Fromage, Light, Corsé,
Onctueux et riche, Traditionnel "Vieux Continent", "Jardin avec des morceaux". (Rires)
C'est grâce à Howard. C'est le legs d'Howard au peuple américain.
Mais en quoi est-ce important?
C'est en fait, énormément important. Je vais vous expliquer pourquoi.
Howard a fondamentalement changé la manière dont l'industrie alimentaire pense
vous rendre heureux.
L'hypothèse première dans l'industrie alimentaire était
que la façon de deviner ce que les gens voulaient manger--
ce qui les rendait heureux-- était de leur demander.
Pendant des années et des années, Ragu et Prego
avaient des groupes de testeurs qu'ils rassemblaient pour leur dire
"Que voulez-vous dans une sauce spaghetti? Dites-nous ce que vous voulez dans une sauce spaghetti."
Pendant toutes ces années-- 20, 30 ans--
pendant toutes ces sessions avec des groupes de testeurs,
personne n'a jamais dit qu'il voulait une sauce avec plein de morceaux.
Même si au moins un tiers la désirait au plus profond d'eux-mêmes.
(Rires)
Les gens ne savent pas ce qu'ils veulent! D'accord?
Comme Howard aime à le dire: "L'esprit ne sait pas ce que veut la langue."
C'est un mystère!
Un pas très important dans la compréhension de nos propres désirs
et nos goûts est de se rendre compte que nous ne pouvons pas toujours expliquer ce que nous voulons au plus profond de nous.
Si vous demandais à tous, par exemple, dans cette salle, comment vous voulez votre café,
vous savez ce que vous diriez? Tout le monde dirait "Je veux un café noir, riche, torréfié à point."
C'est ce que les gens disent toujours.
Qu'est-ce que vous aimez? Noir, riche, torréfié à point!
Quel pourcentage d'entre vous aiment vraiment du "noir, riche, torréfié à point"?
Selon Howard, entre 25 et 27% d'entre vous.
La plupart d'entre vous aime un café crémeux et pas fort.
Mais vous ne direz jamais à quelqu'un qui vous demande ce que vous voulez:
"Je veux un café crémeux et pas fort." (Rires)
Alors c'est la première chose qu'a faite Howard.
En second lieu, Howard nous a fait prendre conscience--
c'est un autre point très critique--
il nous a fait réaliser l'importance de ce qu'il aime appeler la segmentation horizontale.
Pourquoi est-ce critique? C'est critique parce que
c'est comme ça que raisonnait l'industrie alimentaire avant Howard.
Qu'est-ce qui les obsédait au début des années 80? Ils étaient obsédés par la moutarde.
Notamment, par l'histoire de Grey Poupon. Vous vous souvenez?
On était habitué à deux types de moutardes. La French et la Gulden.
Quel type? De la moutarde jaune. Qu'y a-t-il dans une moutarde jaune?
Des graines de moutarde jaune, du curcuma et du paprika. C'est ce qu'était la moutarde.
Grey Poupon a proposé la moutarde de Dijon.
Beaucoup plus de graines de moutarde brune, un peu de vin blanc, une attaque au nez,
des arômes beaucoup plus délicats. Et qu'ont-ils fait?
Ils l'ont mise dans un petit pot en verre, avec une magnifique étiquette en émail,
on dirait qu'elle vient de France alors qu'elle était faite à Oxnard, en Californie.
Au lieu d'un dollar cinquante pour le pot de 225g,
comme pour la French et la Gulden, ils ont décidé de la vendre à quatre dollars.
Puis ils ont fait ces pubs. Avec le gars en Rolls Royce,
qui mangeait la Grey Poupon, l'autre Rolls Royce qui s'arrête,
et il lui dit: "Vous avez de la Grey Poupon?"
Après tout cela Grey Poupon a décollé!
Pris le contrôle du marché de la moutarde!
La leçon à en tirer était que
la façon de rendre les gens heureux
est de leur donner quelque chose plus cher, à quoi aspirer, n'est-ce pas?
C'est de leur faire oublier ce qu'ils croient aimer maintenant,
et d'atteindre le sommet de l'échelle dans la hiérarchie de moutarde.
Une moutarde meilleure! Une moutarde plus chère!
Une moutarde avec plus de sophistication, de culture et de sens.
Howard a examiné cela et a dit: "c'est faux!"
La moutarde n'a pas de hiérarchie.
La moutarde existe, comme la sauce tomate, sur un plan horizontal.
Il n'y a pas de bonne ou de mauvaise moutarde.
Il n'y a pas de moutarde parfaite ou imparfaite.
Il y a seulement différentes sortes de moutardes qui correspondent à différentes catégories de gens.
Il a fondamentalement démocratisé notre façon de penser au goût.
Pour cela aussi, nous devons à Howard Moskowitz d'énormes remerciements.
La troisième chose qu'a faite Howard et peut-être la plus importante,
est qu'il s'est confronté avec la notion de l'assiette platonique. (Rires)
Qu'est-ce que je veux dire par là?
Pendant très longtemps dans l'industrie alimentaire,
Il y avait une dominance de l'unique manière, parfaite, de faire une assiette.
Vous allez "Chez Panisse", ils vous servent le sashimi rouge
avec des graines de citrouilles grillées dans une espèce de sauce.
Ils ne vous donnent pas cinq choix de sauce, non?
Ils ne diront pas: "voulez-vous la sauce avec des morceaux ou voulez-vous-- non!
Vous avez juste la sauce. Pourquoi? Parce que le chef de "Chez Panisse"
a une notion platonique du sashimi rouge.
C'est comme ça.
Ils le servent de cette façon encore et encore.
Si vous discutez avec lui, il dira,
"Vous savez quoi? Vous avez tort! C'est la meilleure façon pour ce restaurant."
Cette idée dirigeait aussi l'industrie alimentaire commerciale.
On avait une notion, une notion platonique, de ce qu'était la sauce tomate.
D'où cela venait-il? D'Italie.
Qu'est-ce qu'une sauce tomate italienne? C'est un mélange, c'est fin.
La culture de la sauce tomate était fine.
Quand on parlait de sauce tomate authentique dans les années 70,
on parlait de sauce tomate italienne. On parlait des tout premiers ragus.
Dans lesquels il n'y avait pas de morceaux.
Ils étaient fins et on mettait juste un peu
et cela se noyait dans le fond de l'assiette de pâtes.
C'est tout. Et pourquoi y était-on attaché?
Parce qu'on croyait que ce qu'il fallait pour rendre les gens heureux,
1) c'était de donner aux gens la sauce tomate la plus authentique culturellement,
et 2), on pensait que si on leur donnait la sauce tomate la plus authentique culturellement,
ils l'adopteraient.
Cela plairait à un maximum de gens.
La raison pour laquelle nous pensions ainsi--en d'autres termes,
les gens du monde de la gastronomie cherchaient des plats universels.
Ils cherchaient à nous traiter tous d'une manière unique.
Une bonne raison pour eux d'être obsédés par l'idée d'universalité,
était que toute la science, durant le 19e siècle et la plupart du 20e,
a été obsédée par l'universalité.
Les psychologues, les scientifiques de la médecine, les économistes s'intéressaient tous à trouver
les lois qui régissent la façon dont nous nous comportons.
Mais cela a changé, non?
Quelle est la grande révolution scientifique des 10, 15 dernières années?
C'est le changement de la recherche de l'universalité vers la compréhension de la variabilité.
De nos jours en médecine, nous ne voulons pas juste savoir comment
agit le cancer, nous voulons savoir en quoi votre cancer est différent du mien.
Je me dis que mon cancer est différent du vôtre.
La génétique a ouvert la porte à l'étude de la variabilité humaine.
Ce que faisait Howard Moskowitz, cette même révolution
doit avoir lieu dans le monde des sauces tomate.
Pour cela, nous lui devons de grands remerciements.
Une dernière illustration de la variabilité, et c'est-- oh, désolé.
Non seulement Howard y croyait mais il est allé plus loin,
en disant que lorsque nous poursuivons des principes universels dans l'industrie alimentaire
non seulement nous commettons une erreur mais en plus nous ne nous rendons guère service.
L'exemple qu'il a utilisé est celui du café.
Il a beaucoup travaillé dessus, avec Nescafé.
Si je devais vous demander de nommer une marque de café
-- une variété, une torréfaction -- qui vous rendrait tous heureux,
et que je vous demande par la suite de le classer sur une échelle de préférence
le score moyen dans cette salle serait de 60 sur une échelle de 0 à 100.
Si, en revanche, vous me permettez de vous diviser en groupes,
peut-être trois ou quatre groupes,
et de faire du café spécifique à chaque groupe,
vos scores passeraient de 60 à 75 ou même 78.
La différence entre un café à 60 et un café à 78
est la différence entre un café qui vous crispe
et un café qui vous rend super content.
C'est là, je pense, la plus belle leçon de Howard Moskowitz.
En embrassant la diversité des êtres humains,
nous trouverons un chemin plus sûr vers le bonheur.
Merci.